well what happened is simply an ongoing
situation which is a sort of Groundhog
Day situation between Israel and Hamas
has been since summers sees the Gaza
almost a decade ago after israel
withdrew which is that hamas fires
rockets into israel israel responds by
firing at launch sites and now in his
latest operation and increasingly over
weekend at the houses of Hamas leaders
whether they're in them or not and so
that it's severe ongoing we've had
several rounds of this before it happens
about for every 18 months two years
what's interesting about this one
incidentally is that there's been less
of the familiar replay in the
international community than theirs
tended to were leaving well last time
2012 instance of the time for their a
fairly large international outcry United
Nations William Hague and so on this
time actually has been a lot more muted
I think that's possibly because the
international community now realizes
what the status quo is in the region and
that the status quo is pretty
unsustainable albeit they're very keen
to sustain it that is a status quo in
which has launches rocket is low
retaliates and everyone calls for a
ceasefire I think you're missing to
realize that that call for a ceasefire
too early for achieving some operational
objectives is actually part of the
problem that's quite interesting thing
you raise that Douglas what are the
operational objectives I think lots of
people aren't responding because they
just don't understand quite what the
aims are on both sides I mean I must
want to show their you know tougher than
they actually are popping what's Israel
trying to demonstrate what is the
objective c the simple objective is to
try to stop rockets being fired into the
body of israel by militants it started
in sending islamic jihad then ms joined
in him as it stopped firing rockets for
a while that israel wants to stop the
Rockets being fired I mean stop its
citizens living in air raid shelters and
so on it seems to me and I probably
seems to sort of most people that are in
fact you might create an environment
Gaza where people are furious with
Israel and more likely to grow up to be
to support Hamas and fire rockets
themselves I mean yes it's possible but
that's a long term but as you say the
same conflict happening every two years
and in part it's because you know both
sides of creating some conditions too
yes angry young men the problem that is
relevant each other next time yeah the
problem with for the lives of the guards
are on everyone has with the Gaza is
very hard to see how you get hammers out
or mass we are a peaceful didn't we
earlier this year about factor down all
the troops are worse than Hamas mm-hmm
yes there are Isis dial group yeah it's
not entirely clear to me if her a mess
is directly responsible for these rocket
Braves I mean is one thing getting a
mass to grooming you know to say right
stop this to make it okay we will so we
can't stop it engine other guys are
firing let's face it pretty low-grade
rocket speed of nothing like the
artillery which Israel it's got yet as
disposable so it sounds bad 8,000 rock
is fired into Israel but then I'm not
quite sure how many have died as a
result of those rockets well we know 120
have died in the last few days I vesa I
says significance em death tool isn't it
yes I mean not in the history of
conflict but in terms of inequality of
this conflict of death ratio of course
and I just what I mean Israel has a
major problem on this which is it is too
good at protecting its own services its
citizens now if Hamas instead of
building bunkers and then building
mosques and schools on top of the
bunkers and storing Rockets under the
mosques and schools instead actually
build bunkers which they allowed their
citizens to go into there would be fewer
deaths in Gaza likewise because Israel
has been hacked to build and including
in them you know city like Ashkelon
further north as well shelters for the
citizens of the country and then
additionally this time round has the the
Iron Dome as it's called which is
shooting down many of the incoming
rockets it means that the Israeli death
toll is I mean at the moment it's nil in
this conflict last time there are
several people killed but it means these
valleys is almost too good now if
letting his own civilians not by the way
in the eyes of millions of Israel of
course but in
I international community who is it work
if a hundred Israelis have killed by now
many people in the international
community would actually be very happy
they want a hundred Israelis to be
killed through so they want an equality
of conflict they think that there's an
inequality of a conflict currently and
that somehow to have as it were a
proportionate conflict mornings have
equal deaths design is a little bit what
country on earth would actually
celebrate who were hundreds really
skilled well quite a lot of the
countries in the region would celebrate
of course we know that much although
interesting enough by the way something
hasn't been picked up enough is that
some of the Egyptian press is actually
coming out against Garza at the moment
some there have been a couple of columns
in the last few days in Egyptian press a
one even saying thank goodness for
Benjamin Netanyahu let us hope that
there are more people like him that come
along because Hamas is our problem as
well and but generally speaking I mean
of course you know in the region has not
much love for Israel and I'd argue in an
international community there wasn't
much love for Israel but to get back to
this point about the the inequality of a
conflict it is very striking we haven't
actually had much of the talk of the
disproportionate thing this time that
has not been long since 2006 although
that could yet come back one of the
under commented upon things in recent
days has been the firing of rockets from
the south of Lebanon Israel obvious he
already has a problem on at Syrian
border in recent months for the first
time in some decade that's been able to
fire across the Syrian border in
retaliation so it's already got a very
low level with a level of conflict on
the Syrian border it's got the problem
in the Gaza with hammers it's got the
problem in the Sinai with are kinda like
elements and then it's got the problems
in the West Bank review on going if it's
also got the problems in the north with
Lebanon then it will be fighting a war
on almost every front and the only thing
to be said is that Israel currently is
quite good at doing that it's learn how
to do it it's done it before it's done
it most most years since its birth and
it'll probably do it again
you